my first recipe is packed with strong
confident flavors and with the oven
taking the strain is a pleasure to make
[Music]
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast one of the secrets to slow
cooking is to be robust and really get
stuck in big bold flavors work
brilliantly well so don't be precious
this is gutsy cooking at its absolute
best
these are lambres a beautiful cheap cut
and they're sort of tucked alongside the
rib they've been boned out the skin has
been taken off I'm going to roll them
stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
seasoning season them both sides inside
and out really important it doesn't look
like a real weighty dense cut of meat
but once it's beautifully slow braised
it's just like melting lamb it's
incredible I'm going to season the
breasts with some dried oregano
put a heat in there some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
[Applause]
amazing
salted anchorries in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb so the
balance of flavors work beautifully
now pull it down towards you and roll
that nice and tightly
that's what I'm looking for
a
string
just need to tie them three times one at
each end and one in the middle
I fell in love with this dish years ago
when I first started working in Paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
Pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
look at that oil nice and hot
lemon
it's really important to get some nice
color on there whilst they're Browning
slice The Onion
the lamb is going to be cooking for two
and a half hours so don't slice the
onions too thinly otherwise they'll burn
garlic and leave whole got a color on
them look at that beautiful
take them out onions in and garlic
straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans why of all the
goodness isn't that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
argano nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there and I'll
do the onions what I did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding to the bottom of the
pan they get nice and crispy next my
black olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
a rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now where are our tomatoes
puncher
those plum tomatoes
then simply place the lamb breasts back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
lid on
into the oven
170. two two and a half hours and forget
about it
whoa
beautiful
all that was reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
it's kept its color look at that that's
braised beautifully very carefully
little bits there it's nice off pull off
the little bits of string
this is why I get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there but that is a
very cheap cut of meat on salivating I
love this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
and amazing
Rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
hit it on
it looks incredible
and that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap Cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
my next recipe is all about great
flavors and it is as cheap and easy to
make
as it is delicious
spicy sausage rice whatever you're
cooking the secret to making great food
is to ensure you lock in every last
ounce of flavor in that pan and this
spicy sausage rice does exactly that
[Music]
foreign
take these spicy sausages and Pierce
that skin because I want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas Red
Onion less acidic than a big white
Spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because I want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never Rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start the caramelizing
a mouth of my pepper slice around
wasting nothing
I want to see that sort of little core
those tips in the center no fine dice
pepper the rice is going to be cooking
for 20 minutes so I want the veg to sort
of have texture after it's cooked
peppers in a bit of garlic two nice
cloves
just slap down
off of the shell
garlic in
now I want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the Skin's off and the real flavor of
that spicy Italian sausage is gonna come
through what's great about this recipe
is that you can use any type of sausage
to get the flavor and the heat you want
I've gone for the spicy Italian but it's
just as good with mergys or chorizo
a teaspoon
in give it that really nice Smoky flavor
rice in
and we're going to sort of basically
sear the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of
soaked the rice for 30 seconds and it
takes on all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice stock in bring
it up to the boil turn it down and let
it simmer
double stock to Rice turn that gas down
and let it simmer so 12 to 15 minutes
just give it the occasional stir keep an
eye on it now get ready to finish it
sliced spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring onions in tomatoes in off with
the gas really important otherwise
everything becomes overcooked flat leaf
parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that is an
amazing way to take spicy Italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]